this is a story about the end of reality
at the end of the world at the end of
the idea of one consensus world
diving in let's nod to alan watts who
once said there's no sense in clinging
to the rocks that are falling with you
fictions make us human and always have
starting forty thousand years ago with
the lion mensch sculpture a lion-headed
man carved from mammoth bone
we've lived in our imaginations reality
only exists in contrast with
and has always required the unreal in
the last few hundred years
we've moved from trust and hearsay in
recordings as photography and
phonography matured and became
admissible as court evidence
allowing us to get strangely lazy about
what it is we consider
authentic philosopher regina rini of
york university calls this
the epistemic backstop it's part of what
has allowed us to scale social
coordination from local networks to a
global economy
but it's a prosthetic that has eroded
other vital capabilities
over the last few years thanks to nvidia
adobe google
open ai and others we've seen an
explosive evolution of machine learning
tools
that produce real seeming but fraudulent
synthetic media
by now most people have seen buzzfeed's
jordan peel barack obama deep fake
or the countless mark zuckerberg and
vladimir putin deep fakes
and it's clear how easily these could be
deployed
and will be deployed as political
weapons
but there are subtler issues with apps
like zhao and reface
which let you put your own face into
movies and music videos
democratizing this for masquerade but
opening an attack vector for identity
theft
is concerning but vocal forgery may be
even more worrisome because fewer people
are aware
of how sophisticated it has gotten in my
2017 sci-fi short story an
oral history of the end of reality i
imagined how you may one soon
one day soon risk having your voice
stolen simply by answering the phone
the escalating arms race between forgery
and forensics is really just a
continuation of the forces
that drove humankind to pioneer modern
science in the first place
after all the more perspectives in
agreement the better
there is a silver lining here in that
this undercuts our arrogance
bringing scientific rigor home to roost
and forcing us to ask
sophisticated questions about our
confidence in so-called facts
new conceptions of reality will be far
more nuanced and multi-dimensional than
those of the present day
but for now the threats are apocalyptic
and new literacy is desperately needed
only a few projects such as michael
morgenstern's i dared my best friend to
ruin my life
have emerged to help people understand
how to navigate these vertiginous new
social landscapes
but lying is nothing new and people have
always abused trust
it's already the case that world powers
act as if reality is what you make it
just look at the explosion of fake news
our conceit that recordings are more
trustworthy than hearsay is a huge
exploit in the code of society
collective action problems require a
narrative
cohesion to weave the social fabric of
our future and the manufacture of
convincing counterfeits is a kind of
black magic
by all accounts it's fair to say that
information warfare
is magical warfare which means the end
of the modern hubris of naive realism
and requires us to reclaim some aspects
of pre-modernity
living in the future may ultimately feel
more like living in a world of an
indigenous cosmology in which the
imaginal
is on equal ontological footing with the
physical world
which brings us to the pragmatism of
fiction most of the brain doesn't
differentiate between the real and the
unreal which is why fiction is so
powerful
why first theater and now cinema have
held such power over us
visualization exercises are a mainstay
of wisdom traditions worldwide
an ancient tool to develop and
internalize our highest potentials
the modern world is simply waking up to
the instrumental nature of fictions
as a force for shaping collective
behavior for instance
artist stephanie lep's project deep
reckonings makes explicit deep fakes
of powerful abusers taking
responsibility for their actions
helping us imagine what it would look
like for them to assume accountability
and maybe even moral leadership other
projects like
dali lives bring history back to life
mit's deep empathy
motivates human rights action by showing
us ruined versions of privileged cities
putting the affluent in the shoes of
those suffering from global catastrophe
deep fakes can help us imagine better
versions of ourselves
much like the established use of mirrors
in physical therapy to trick the brain
into imagining wounded body parts as
whole
the fact is we have always lived in our
imagination
and reality is the most pernicious and
dangerous fiction of them all
deep fakes may make it harder for us to
agree on which myths we should act
on but the real world was always a
mirage
and we only stand to gain by leaving it
behind
thank you